hi I'm Greg hi I'm amber amber placer is
back - amber flats are on YouTube you
know find her channel called plaster
rific what's your channel called just my
name amber clastic what's the URL it's
Amber plaster 22 so it's youtube.com
slash a member plus or 22 go to her
Channel watch her videos she talked
movies and [ __ ] - yeah go to it they
watch trailer number 1 this is not the
first trailer I don't know why it's
being titled that whatever you know the
deal guys we watch it then we talk about
it they watch you ready for this amber
I'm ready for the sexiness did you see
the show at all yeah yeah yeah I saw a
few episodes you're a half after all
yeah yeah okay yeah we go pathologic ER
Megan
[Music]
welcome to Baywatch Ark is the elite of
the elite
with hot so love this very Beach come on
feed macaques a little bigger
let's go out my front of all you guys
music this year I restore the Baywatch
plan their one direction here football
fun I'm not really what we do here that
keeps me getting sunburned occasionally
stop them from drowning
[Laughter]
gosh in fact run mud get body on our
team and it all started when she took
over some people are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
effect the truth is one of you will
probably die he can please what no
[Music]
the only one to think this is clearly a
job in the brief Thank You blue eye
diamond you got one job make sure the
right you white people don't run it's a
quick depending in from I'll oh yeah
want to cover yeah little to undercover
[Music]
crazy yeah take a born-again tsunami why
are we in the morgue you got to get some
hard evidence what coming food you down
now we are you touch it's just a little
dead man's back automatically was back
on you nothing baby
Oh do way way does it again Joey does it
again I'm such a fan callin sack getting
Jumbo's here Court you go ahead thank
you yeah it's my after five minutes ever
ever I told you 5 min and 1 he didn't
miss five minute wanted dress very fair
[ __ ] anger you're a James in a Coleman
I heard no warning [ __ ] Apple you
feel really high who are you
amber what do you think I've given my
thoughts on other shows I know what you
think oh I thought was funny I love
movies that pretend to be an action film
and are actually just a laugh out loud
coming and now I get the same thing in
the form of the rock Johnson well yeah
this is to me I keep saying it's like
like what ships is 21 Jump Street
ever since 21 Jump Street came out
they're doing this thing where they
reboot shows into action comedies but
they're more in the comments back from
the action kind of just adds to the
humor of it there's no actually cuz it
looks like this looks legit cool thing
they were talking adjuster I wasn't like
this is legit cool action when they cuz
funny is that they think they're cool
action stars in the movie yeah but that
gap Ron is doing jobs are going to have
great chemistry together I actually
really like that they kind of gives back
off ever on all over the ship because
he's such a golden boy Oh totally and
he's taking it really really well so
it's always good to see good-looking
people who can make out of themself yeah
good good sack Efron what we've seen
dwayne johnson do this kind of role
several times yeah and we've also seen
that gap on these rolling neighbors very
similar like pretty boy hot shop it
could climbed on a lot so i feel like
putting these two it together they are a
perfect match and because they're both
like hilarious view to happen to be
super sexy at the same time and super
buff in there
they're both busts in their own way so
they complement each because act like
this the more ripped l version or model
like huge yeah it's like 400 pounds
exactly
like 300 pounds of family yeah hundred
thousand we're going to because a rocket
Congress yeah my brother has a channel
that is dedicated at Indian film and the
woman in the trailer who looks like
she's like semi villain Priyanka Chopra
she's amazing she's beautiful
she is she's actively one of the
prettiest people in the world actively
one of the prettiest people in the world
that so that's an interesting baby sure
your wife is not going back on it she's
been that show Quantico she's a lead on
that show Kiwanuka
okay I didn't I didn't I didn't you you
know shows a lot of people don't know
afterbuzz I'm into TV a GSA and this is
going to be an army yeah that's the
other thing too that these movies do
they send them into r-rated comedy
there's a lot of vulgarity there too
interesting is the shows are that series
who is based on like 21 Jump Street
ships Baywatch are so far for me are a
type of show yeah but then they do these
comedies that are like real are their
own spin on it right yeah this is a
remake got you nobody wants
I can't wait to see the cameos of a
Hasselhoff and have lab you know there's
going to yeah I think I think they're
credited in the IME being actually they
have to be I will have it have like
there's no hair this is an animal bird
oh yeah
so many great comedy people and so many
supermodels what more right eye
I think chips looks kind of pretty funny
actually but I'm not too sure about that
I'm like more than confident this is
going to be a really good time yeah like
I don't doubt it I feel like no matter
what I'm going to enjoy this movie I'd
be very surprised of it at lower than
like a 60 percent on Rotten Tomatoes I
think yeah I think the rock is going to
I would say safest movie but make it oh
don't have been too cheesy without him I
feel like a lot of its gonna depend on
the chemistry it's just like our
neighbors depended on or Central
Intelligence depends on the both of them
working well together yeah I think
here's this is the same concept it's
about the tooth the two if they work
well together
the
to work with the other Catholics the
woman in this trailer don't look funny
they just look like donning oh did you
know all the Jews are funny yeah I don't
know any of these women for being
particularly funny but I hope that
they're given some funny ones the guy
did Horrible Bosses brought out a really
funny sexy performance from Jennifer
Aniston Queen but do we know Jennifer
asked us from coming from front so we
know she'd get a comedy she is good I
would like to see the woman be a little
more funny - yeah you know or at least
make it a joke that like they're only
hot they're something like make make
some type of self-aware they might lean
into it a little bit more yeah was that
that girl uh she's from another movie
where she also got made fun of for being
hot
Oh Kelly Roark batch nope I was thinking
of her with some anyway that supermodel
is known for being curvy and she'd
always like a hundred-pound Amy Schumer
no I'm remember her name later and as I
was her and she's been in a few movies
and they try to make her funny and like
the joke is I was like she's so pretty
and you're like cool rebel Wilton no
she's legitimately very thin but she's
known in the modeling world for being
curvy I know there's a rule of three to
the comedy bit but I can't think of a
third over-wing chick way machine is
pretty said now Hagen yeah we'll go with
that rule is if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe for a bit I
thought it was going well
it just ends up being a garbage and we
regretted it ever since it happened
things happen you know the Chevy guy
kind of reminded me of Melissa
McCarthy's role on every movie no
specification rising they're all really
hot and she's like the really out of
shape one yeah oh you need one of them I
love that they have a character like
that babe why that's a great idea that
was nice because they watch is known for
all being like perfect bodies running in
slow-mo so I want to see this chubby boy
running in slow-mo talking chubs are in
yeah I get way more gay guys setting me
up these days and anything yes yeah no
women but I'm certain mimics water
that's the true mark of a flattering
comment though is a gay man thinks that
you're doing
no it's an honest feedback gay guys like
me way more than women do the target
market I'm going for her the highest
compliment at all listen guys Billy
Meachem requested this longtime follower
he's the first one to request it so
congratulations Billy Meachem your name
got mentioned by my voice my sexy true
lunch with the word sharpened ibid its
voice subscribe to the real rejects full
of intelligence a hammer plastered type
and hammer blaster on youtube you'll
find her [ __ ] channel go there yes
movie [ __ ] I did on afterbuzz TV and
she's amber plaster on everything on
everything everyone Instagram and
Twitter all the links are in the
description boxes go there and enjoy
yourself a good time yeah goodbye